greetings from podcastville it's monday
the 17th of august you bad [ __ ]
the church is brought to you by
draftkings listen
i know you saw the ufc on saturday night
[ __ ] tremendous
sports have been up in the air as a
pelican who stole my hot dog in michigan
you don't know what's going on
draftkings is a sure thing
no more bookies and dark alleys meeting
them at a diner on [ __ ] thursday with
their [ __ ] attitude
[ __ ] them but when you want where you
want you don't even have to leave your
house
this week the nba playoffs start you
[ __ ] believe that
download the draftking sports book now
all new users
get a sign up bonus of up to one grand a
thousand dollars
draftking sportsbook is legit that based
right here in the us and your money is
secure
so get it on the action right now
download draftking sportsbook
now and use code church plus for a
limited time
the church family all new users get a
sign up
of a bonus of a thousand dollars you
didn't hear me
you get a grand when you get draftking
sportsbook app
and use code church plain and simple
only
at draftkings sportsbook and here's the
part the lawyers make me say
you got to be 21 or older you
got to be in new jersey indiana or
pennsylvania
only new jersey i'm coming [ __ ]
deposit bonus requires a 25 times play
look through
and restrictions do apply see
draftkings.com
sportsbook for details you got a gaming
problem
there's help call 1-800 gambler or
if you're in indiana call 1-800-9 with
it and
tell them uncle joey sent you but if
you're ready to [ __ ] gamble
download the draftking sportsbook app
right now
and use code church the church is also
brought to you by and i want to welcome
gabby you're like joe who's gabby gabby
insurance
right now we're all looking at ways to
save money you might not be working but
the rent car payments
and everything else is due when's the
last time you looked at how much you're
paying every month on car insurance huh
or home workers huh every month
you're overpaying for this stuff get a
lower rate
for the exact same coverage you already
have and pay less
and keep your coverage with gabby gabby
takes the pain
out of shopping for insurance it's
straightforward
just go to gabby.com
capital j joey to see how much you'll
you'll save
it's tot it's totally free to check your
rate and there's no obligation
take two minutes right now right now
you're not doing [ __ ] gabby.com
joey right now and see how much money
you can save
on your car and homeowners insurance go
to gabby.com
joey that's gabby g a
b i dot com slash joey
and save money gabby.com
joey kick this [ __ ] mule
oh [ __ ] it all starts [ __ ] today all
right no more [ __ ] excuses this is
the year
[Music]
[Music]
oh yeah oh yeah
since i'm counting down the last
episodes of the church
i wanted to bring this young gentleman
in who i've basically grown up with
uh and he's a g in his own right mr sam
[ __ ] tripoli i know you're
looking at the studio going joey what
happened you got evicted
no we're cleaning this [ __ ] out
we took everything out
walls tables
in like three hours we work like if you
drop a car off in harlem and go see your
grandmother upstairs
when you come down there's just a
chassis that's what happened here those
are the people i run with
they [ __ ] came in here and they're
like we might as well take the walls
down
they took the tables down and uh with
bare bones
what's happening sammy trips well it's
honored to be on the uh last week dude i
i might start crying i'm super sad
everybody's leaving
i'm gonna miss you guys very much that
sucks
but because everybody's leaving you'll
be here holding it down like a
[ __ ] tin foil on it
i see that 10-4 broke the top 40. on
itunes you're making waves yeah
you know sam tripps i got to tell you
something when i met you 20 years ago
okay let me get this out of the way
right now because you're going to make
your opinion also and i'm going to tell
you why you're going to die
sam tripley was a [ __ ] punk
sam tripley started a fight with me one
night on the stage
that i could not understand people were
like what's his problem i don't know
he's my brother because i was talking
about an armenian drug dealer
who i spoke to yesterday and he goes i
have a gun for you
i just talked to him yesterday that's
even though i don't do drugs
he's still one of my best friends and
then about a week later you got into an
argument with the bartender
the filipino bartender yeah i was an
[ __ ] and i didn't know what happened
i disappeared from the store i'm still
now i'm hearing great things
little by little ahri and you were doing
a podcast
i'll never forget one night ari going
have you gone down
to see tripoli's dirty show
and i go you know he hasn't invited me
and i don't want to crash like i hate
when people do that like i didn't know
you did this sam
really you didn't know i did this and i
go how was sam and he goes you know man
and the way he said it to me he goes
it's great he's great because he's an
environment
that's his thing he's the king of
madness
he wants the [ __ ] he wants each other
he wants the chicken the bikini
you know and uh you got a bunny suit the
guy in the bunny suit he disappeared you
cracked him
he was the first owen benjamin he quit
comedy
lost 80 pounds and wrote a book on how
to [ __ ]
survive in hollywood dude have you seen
him lately
i see skippy once he's a great kid he's
a great guy dude
he's you know he's just uh living that
life dude he's just one of those guys
what did he write the book about it was
something about eating meat and then
he would have like this patreon before
there's patreon where women
would pay for him to take pictures of
his dick
do you have like a really good dick or
something he's got supposedly a [ __ ]
hog
like a big hog and women would pay
for him to put in exotic areas and
photoshop in different places dude my
dick doesn't have anyone on its patreon
nobody else do you understand why harvey
weinstein was the fearless leader of
hollywood this is the reason why
because women pay comics for dick pics
now you know
don't sit there and judge and say well
rick gervais never raped anybody
keep believing that you know i'm saying
give it time the la times will scoop it
up any day now
uh it's just weird what we've been
through the last
when did you show up at the comedy store
2000's
yeah i moved out when i was just about
to turn
26 so i was about 25 so
i'd say that's about a little like
i guess i lived in like 99 i think i
moved out there
99 our connection was pablo
we were friends through pablo the best
we were
right away you know i hosted on sundays
i took to you
we were dear friends i loved you and
then the one night with the call out on
stage i'm like what did i do
am i gonna have to fight triple i don't
fight no i i remember
what i said and i you know it's just one
of those when you make a joke
and it's like it doesn't come out the
way you wanted it to
and you're like oh [ __ ] that sounded way
meaner i didn't mean it like that
and uh you know i i you know
i had what happened was i was saying
that joke and it was working
and one night i said in the original
room and when i got off stage
a [ __ ] armenian came up to me furious
and he's like
you should not be saying that joke
because
armenians yes we make mistakes
people think we're gangsters and when
you say those things with gangsters
and what people have to realize about
armenian is what the turkish did to us
oh yeah we have to do with it and he
gave me an ear beating about the turks
he bought me a drink i was coked up so i
took the ear beat you know when you're
coked up
you just yes on the death yeah the turks
i keep them too
you know what i'm saying like it was
just dude you gave me advice
to get me picked up like i you
gave me you told me you love this one
joke
so duncan calls me and is like this is
what you do you did one joke about your
ethnic group
one joke about your parents and then do
your favorite bit
and i'm like okay joey loves that
[ __ ] bit about asians on ecstasy i'm
gonna end on that bit
so i did a bit about uh being armenian
going to the beach
my mom power walking and then i ended up
on uh
you know uh ending about asians love and
ecstasy
and paul mooney saved me and i told the
story and i'm just waiting for it to
come out on saturday
i know if that showtime dock ever drops
about and i say the m word in it but
paul mooney called me the m word like
only a week earlier
so then it was showcasing and he sat
down
and he uh was telling mitzi that you
know
they should pick me up so you and you
and paul mooney are the reason i got
picked up at the stores because you guys
were telling me uh all that stuff
i remember i i i thought the joke was
something along the lines of like
if you made it through your act any you
know just like because
you were bigger than than we saw and i
you know i i did that with dom bears too
like i said a dumb joke that i meant to
be and it came off as
just really mean and you know i super
regretted it no i didn't care it wasn't
like i was gonna fist fight you
i just didn't know where you were coming
from we were dear friends
following you is an education dude you
got to survive
man so it's like you say a little joke
just to get you into it now when i
follow you dude i go
first five minutes nobody's listening
because they just saw joey diaz and i'm
gonna be charlie brown's mom
on stage and i just have to sit in it
and just be okay that five minutes i
gotta let the room reset
when did you go from crazy sam to
business sam
when i go you know i've struggled with
sobriety i have sobriety now but i had
five years and i've been i've been
fighting with it but i always went to
meetings
and i just learned a lot like
my father i love my dad to death i love
him so much
he's a wonderful man he's a flawed
character
and i started seeing my me start making
the decision
that started acting like he was acting
and i go aw mama
turn out like i'm going to make the same
mistakes
so i started changing my mind like i got
raised to be very paranoid
you know and i and then i was lashing
out and i go i don't want to be that
that guy and then it just slowly takes
time
but i have that in me and i can flare up
and and on top of that
i'm super sensitive i used to think i
was dead on the inside but i'm
super scared and like harry says
and i have a [ __ ] trigger dude and i
i like oh and then i'm like oh what'd i
do that night
i grovel and i'm like i gotta call my
brother up i
blew up on him today and i feel awful
about it but
that's kind of the work in progress that
i am right now you know
and then you know you just over t it's
like when you start living a life like
you really want it's like you stopped
drowning
and you just like okay this is okay this
is you know and you start to chill out
and then you start realizing like
everything that was important to you
doesn't really matter it doesn't really
matter it doesn't really
once you get that one
comedy wind that all this [ __ ] doesn't
matter
when your manager comes up to you and
says listen do jokes about family
so i could sell you to a sitcom and
you're like have you considered lighting
yourself on fire
have you ever considered that go [ __ ]
your mother you know this
we take rules like listen don't be dirty
in front of this guy
oh we actually followed them which i
never did
if you told me not if you had the balls
to come up to me
and say don't be dirty unless it was a
weekend
and even then i dread on a fine line
but you cannot tell a comic what to do
we did not become comics
for you to tell me what to do i knew the
third year
that i was never going to be on
letterman orlando i knew it
how much of you when they tell you not
to do something makes you want to do it
more oh i can just see you doing that on
purpose
i don't oh i have not you have to look
at a person's psyche
we never look at a person's psyche you
know
i meet sam tripoli we go do a couple
rogue gigs together
in the car we gotta talk about something
we talk about his [ __ ] [ __ ]
brother
my brother's not [ __ ] i love him
very much i'm being an idiot i'm just
saying that i was an [ __ ]
i'm talking to you about my mother dying
yeah i'm talking to you and then
we do three more gigs we spill our beans
to each other
and we make an assessment about each
other you know what
this is the third gig that joey has
thrown me
a bone he's not a bad guy he's paying my
rent
now we start looking at people they're
paying our rent
they're doing me a [ __ ] favor so now
when i go on an audition
and they're looking for an armenian even
if it's from my role
i want if i don't get it i want my
brother to get it yeah
these are the things you have to do to
move forward
as an individual in any career
in any career sometimes you gotta bite
the bullet
whenever i go for a mafia audition if i
don't
see certain people at that audition i
call them
and i go go down there yeah but what am
i gonna tell them
are you a [ __ ] stupid yeah you got
get a black shirt on with a tie
they're in business to find the right
person
that a casting director's job is to find
the right person if you look at that
breakdown
and you think you're the right person
get up
and get down there we'll figure it out
once we get down there
the little gay assistant will come out
and go i don't see your name on the list
oh my god let me let me ask the castle
director
and he'll go in the back she'll come out
take a look at you
and say let him read and there must have
been a mistake here
there's no mistake the mistake was you
let a gangster in this
room you let a gangster in this
[ __ ] room so
for me like when you look at and i'm not
putting nobody down
i don't want [ __ ] short clips about
this
when you looked at sarah silverman yeah
when we got here
yeah sarah silverman the guy who talks
about bacon
uh jim gaffigan great guy
uh i can name five of them but i can't
right now because of the ebola virus
that structures my brain plus i'm on
antibiotics
i can name five people who are
predetermined
to end up with something in this town
the first time you see him
oh yeah and you see the three jews in
the room watching them
once they show up with three jews and
they're watching them
it's two jews to the management that
third jew he's the one that tells the
network what to do
okay i've seen that with
uh the kid who died
god rest his soul mitch hedberg
i saw it with i could probably tell you
five
comics who as soon as they hit la
they were destined to be starved you
know i knew it was gonna be
taylor tomlinson from the moment i saw
her stand up i go
and i used to call her the future every
time i saw her do say i go
that's the few and we're just now seeing
it and i don't even think we're close to
where we're gonna go isn't she like 25
dude she and she's and she's an assassin
on stage dude i watched her for her
first time
19 years old was hosting for me and i
thought she had attitude
but she's just shy right dude went up
and did
old black man crowd work like old black
man crowd work because she'd been doing
church shows
since she was like 12. so she was used
to being in front of crowds and just
lighting people up and everything i saw
i saw it was gonna happen
i saw it was gonna happen man yeah you
see those in some
you never know who's gonna blow up but
you know who's gonna work for sure
you know who's gonna work you don't know
who's gonna blow up
when sam tripley got the show on spike
[Laughter]
i was like everybody i spoke to
was happy for sam because sam wasn't
supposed to get that show
that show was supposed to go to some
goofy white dude i couldn't be
managed by a host company and and then
you watch the show and you're like why
is this guy hosting the show
yeah i'm with you dude you know and when
you got that show
i gotta be honest so many
people were happy two
so many people were inspired
because you know what now we could
attack other networks
it's not just cbs sam is on spite
getting thrown
by a black guy into the fire
rampage you know and when they
canceled it you were depressed for an
hour
yeah you knew that this was part of the
game you accepted it
i stayed away from the store for seven
years i remember when i left the store
i liked you when i came back to the
store
i fell in love with the man you had
become oh dude you're too nice
you had become a man of comedy now
you had become what was told to me
10 years ago that when you go back into
this game
you have to go back as an elder and you
have to set an example for the younger
guys you have to act a certain way
you had lead down there you paid leave
you paid everybody
you gave everybody stage time along the
way as much as you could give people
and for comics at home listening young
comics
for plumbers for electricians for
lawyers
listen sometimes you gotta take a bullet
sometimes you gotta do the wrong thing
to get to the right place
you know what this kid ain't ready for
10 minutes
but who the [ __ ] am i to decide let him
go up there the same way
louis c.k put me up for a guest set in
seattle in 95
okay it all comes to circle
and i gotta be honest with you you were
one of the guys that really had
highlighted
that you know there was these guys
working at the comedy store didn't even
have comedy experience
and they're trying to nickel and dime
you and meanwhile they're living in a
two-bedroom [ __ ] apartment up in the
hills
off of your sweat you didn't do that
yeah you said i'm giving everybody an
envelope
i'm coming down here with edibles i got
a masseuse in the back
i got [ __ ] food there was joe's pizza
it was just a [ __ ] experience and
that's why people hate comics who open
up clubs
because they forget of what was
important in that green room
it's not the big things i don't want you
to plan a helicopter ride around utah i
don't need that
it's when i go to my [ __ ] hotel room
there's a cheese platter it's when i go
to the green room
there's the sandwich i like they call
the head little things i got you that
pizza
thanks you know bill blumen writes you
go to boston
he shows up with a pie in between shows
from
regina regina's pizza the best in boston
you know there's little things that
people could do to make your day
when i did those shows for you you made
me feel
i never complained one time about where
my spot was
i went down there it was an experience
you paid me i went in the original room
and i would go home sometimes you did
thursdays
sometimes you what's the kid
that ran sunday nights mark zaratella
yeah he was very good to me yeah
i think of those guys they go thank god
that
you know when you and i started at the
store dude you and i both know that
there was no main room
it was tuesday friday and saturday
and we weren't allowed in on tuesday if
you get what i'm saying yeah
i'm saying it was pure african-american
night
yeah great night hosted by joe torre
just tremendous you'd see everybody down
there yeah denzel
the [ __ ] the director it was great
but the main room when we first got
there
was not really a thing it wasn't dude
and it was like more of a side party
room
coke bad decisions just hanging out dude
and
you know i miss those days but i
it was like insane when i used to think
about
all these dudes i came up with man and
how you guys all did my show and we
could all make money ma'am we could
leave with a grip
of loot and go home we didn't have to
fly anywhere to do it
we got to get in you know and i would
always like i go man trust me i know
where to put you in the lineup he'll be
like oh i'm like no dude
and it's like like let's say you went up
and you always think you'd flame to the
room
i'd have to go in and calm people down
so the next person will come
you know that's why i enjoyed dude i
enjoy putting on a show
they always say oh you're i'm saying i'm
like nah master ceremonies dude it's
totally different thing oh you were
phenomenal
that's what i love you were phenomenal
and people
it's so weird how every comic wants to
get out of the emcee
phase i'm sick of what i'm saying well
it's the strongest position on the field
yeah dude
it's the strongest position on the field
if you can't emcee you're never going to
be tom brady
yeah you're never going to be tom brady
if you can close
and host now you're something dude when
you could close
and host yeah and if you go out there
and
host and put up killers like you did and
then go out in the back and do another
five yeah you
i listened to you one night i think i
was up last and i didn't want to go into
the crowd
and i'm like listen to how tripoli is
sending them home
he's sending them home complete and
there's a line outside to get it at 10
30.
the next show the next show had to get
that show in at certain time or else i'd
be
too tired man it's like and i gotta tell
you this last time
like i stayed away from the store for
seven years
i think i went back in 2013. yeah
and at first it was a lot of fun
you know it was a lot of fun
it took me right back but i knew i went
back an elder
i didn't go back as young joey d is
getting his dick sucked in closets and
[ __ ]
i went back as a [ __ ] yeah that was a
good time
97 through 2000 the comedy store was
what it was
what the [ __ ] do you want me to tell you
and i don't know why
people and they see that as like this
awful thing
it was a magical it was it was more of a
private club at that time
like elle magical described it as that
he goes it's a private club
and like if you were blessed to get in
you were in
and comedy was great but it was also
about
just experiencing uh
just being being an entertainer dude to
what you
we thought entertainment was and we got
a little lost in it
and sometimes the partying was a little
bit harder than the comedy but
man i wouldn't it was so necessary from
that time because
every a a lot of people that were there
during the dead time
were the guys who got a lot of reps in
because
none of the cool kids wanted to go down
there they would stay away like oh [ __ ]
that place it's negative energy negative
energy
so all these cool all these guys got
reps and
reps raps you know and then i i worked
on getting i go okay man we got to build
this lineup
so i i got a lineup of killers and i i
knew the
the the way to get people in you know
and the big thing was to sit
next to mitzi and play defense yeah
so she could see these guys kill i'd sit
down go take it easy
breathe do this this this yeah and let
me play defense
and like you know i i did so much that
it actually [ __ ] me and it put me at
the end of the night but that also made
me stronger so but it was like all those
guys who were there when there was
only a couple people in that or all went
on to become
national mer theater murderers
right do you think if comedy comes back
with the store do you think that's gonna
happen again with since a lot of people
are leaving there's gonna be a lot of
room at
all these clubs for people who stay well
i think
this is gonna be a rare time because
when i got picked up it was a real time
store because she just
gutted the lineup and she got and you
know at my age now
i feel for those comics because they're
like yeah you can't go up anymore and
it's like
but this is my home it's like welcome to
business so i
then i was like so thankful now i i
would i feel for
everybody that that happened to because
that comedy's a cold [ __ ] man
and uh it could be really hard so but
you know ma sebastian brett earns
caparillo
and then ari and all those guys came in
and they
people were getting reps steve byrne
brian calan
uh al magical people were getting a lot
of reps in man in that room got a lot of
reps in there
you were getting a lot of reps in reps i
was getting six
i would call sunday through sunday so
i found out she used to tell me i don't
like when people pick
certain nights boom once i heard her say
that okay
sunday through sunday even if i didn't
want to do comedy i went down there
even if you weren't in the mood you had
to get in the mood you know
because it was fifteen dollars and that
was the biggest check you were gonna get
that [ __ ] week
and if you did four of those you got
sixty dollars you know yeah the main
room on a saturday 250
280 195 you know
all that i was saying all that [ __ ]
man and i couldn't get on the road so i
was just sitting at the store because
you know edgy comedy hadn't really made
its way in every and
i have no problems with but everybody
was looking for a lot of seinfeld so
unless somebody like dice
or joe took down a row it was hard to
get up so i would just sit the store
and just be a crazy man you know just
being crazy dude and
just getting reps man following like the
store is special because
there's no host in my opinion i mean the
room special but
no host so like dude i could tell you i
could tell you
that in my 20-something years three
bombs stand out in my head
that i will never forget one is lisa
lampanelli
one is joey diaz i bombed so bad i sat
in my car and i questioned
is this what i want to do with my life i
just bombed so bad
and then the other one was ron white
those are the three worst bombs i've
ever had in my life in that room and
it's just like
i and i just like okay gotta get up
again and do it again and i i'd always
want to follow those i couldn't follow
like
who who can i follow who's hard to foul
give me that guy give me that guy give
me that guy that's the only way to get
better crack that code dude
i had to follow paul mooney six seven
months
and sit there because i didn't know when
he was coming off
remember those days he just showed up at
11 30
and you were like well i'm done i got
two options i could lose
go home like a [ __ ] or i could watch
watch him learn something
and hopefully get fifteen dollars he'd
walk off the stage half the audience
would leave
yep i had four people to contend with if
you don't think i
learned from those sets i watched paul
mooney dude
crush in front of two people there was
like there was time where there
think about the comedy store and how
crazy it was up until this moment
there were times where two people were
in the audience and we begged them to
run the show so they're like run the
show
so we get our 15 because they they
couldn't start the show unless there was
four people
you needed four people to start the
[ __ ] show
they got two and i watched paul mooney
sit down light on him
and crush for 45 and i go i'm never
going to complain about how many people
in the crowd i'm just gonna go for it
whether it's a packed house or a half a
room i'm on a [ __ ]
throw they have like in new york they
talk about barking but
the sunset strip there's some people
walking but it's mostly driving
in that time when you guys go out and
try to get people to come into the show
or not you just wait
nope
[Laughter]
never bark dude never the only thing i
ever did was
i used to mitzy used to give me 100
tickets
and you wrote your name behind them and
for every ticket that came in with that
you get two dollars oh snap so i would
wait till saturday night at 7
45 and go down there and just give it to
the people online
and they would say how the [ __ ] are you
making 300 a week it's easy
and then you know hey listen you know
you you talk about work
you know as a comic and that's why
i don't know who was in here and we're
talking about the work ethic
you know somebody wrote on the page
uh you know the podcast is done
and somebody wrote look i don't know if
you really know
joey and his ethic joey is far from done
like the work ethic that we had
we developed from comedy you know
i still remember being so broke that i
had money for
a bowl of chili a bacon double
cheeseburger for 98 cents from wendy's
and the salad
and then i would get somebody to drop me
off at universal city
during the week of the 26th and the 31st
when they're all in town for the bowl
games and i would just give out tickets
i would go up there with 500 tickets i
wouldn't stop till i gave them all out
and i knew out of those 20 would go
yeah and if i pulled and i had a
thousand of those tickets in my glove
compartment
if i pulled up and i saw a line of
people outside
you bet your ass i would throw chewie
off i go chewy
i'm going to get a gram give me five
minutes and they'd go all right blah and
i'd walk around and just give out cards
and they finally caught me after about a
year how the [ __ ] are you making 400 a
week
[ __ ] giving away tickets a dude but
i never barked
i could never bark but they didn't hate
you if you hustled
you know and if mitzi loved you she
would uh
tolerate your mess-ups one time i got so
drunk on stage during new year
i walked like literally 320 people
and she banned me for a weekend what did
you say i remember that
i just was so drunk dude i was so drunk
and i walked him and it just
you know i just was i used to dance with
my demons and
you know you know for me for me dude
i i i learned very early i was not one
of the cool kids
when i when i bombed in montreal because
they put me out there corey holcomb who
at that time seemed like a 20-year comic
and that was 20 years ago
you know he was a killer he's killing
now he's killing a funny guy
dude just a murderer and i was brand new
i was a i was a street kid dude i really
hadn't done
any real club comedy i was a vegas comic
who was just gigging in like bars so bar
comedy and theater comedy
two different kind of comedies dude and
i bombed and ah
right there i really like was just
out with the industry and that's such a
thankful thing now i look back on it
because
i just really leaned into my work ethic
which was hustle hustle hustle hustle
hustle
you know and uh i just and then you know
dana who i was with forever um
we just developed a way to to sell the
marquee we came up with a way
comedy swords just want people to go hey
can we sell the marquee we'll put our
names on the marquee
and we'll cut you off a piece coming so
they're like [ __ ] yeah do it
so we'd sell the marquee so we tell
people you drive down the street you'd
see your name on the commie store
marquis boom we're making money
so we just learned to hustle and that's
kind of
you know i'm just blessed that i had had
a work ethic
that was able to uh take advantage of
the opportunities of the internet
that showed up that if i'd been maybe 20
years earlier
who knows if this would ever happen it's
just a real blessing
it's crazy a day to help and i tell
people
that the answer sometimes is right in
front of your eyes
my career did not change until i
involved terry in my life
yeah for years i would just not talk to
her about it wasn't her business
i think finally like in 2004 she would
go so where you going for how much
and she was going to call him back and
tell him you want this much and if he
doesn't give it to you
i'd rather have you at home for dana
when dana
i you know i didn't have a real manager
forever but i get opportunities and you
know as an artist you just want to take
the opportunities
which is hilarious because i used to
have adult film start so the naughty
show
came from i did the vivid video tour
with these one two guys
and i would just crush in front of the
crowd and i always go you know the key
to everything is finding your crowd
right so i'm like this is my crowd right
so they stopped doing it but then i
started
seeing other people pop up i'm like i
should do this
so i started doing that and the big
reason i did the naughty show is because
i got tired of going places and being
told i had to be a clean comic
i wanted a room where i could do stand
up the way
i like to do stand up were you being was
it being told to you a lot
oh yeah what club owners do you remember
hey man get all the time could you work
clean dude this is a seven o'clock
show i'm like this is who i am
and uh you know i made a mistake of a uh
uh of you know
uh thinking that because it was a
communist or comic i also had a
following
on the road so i just wasn't selling
tickets so the combination of me being a
crazy person
and not selling any tickets at that time
made it really hard to get on the road
even though i thought i was doing great
i didn't really know the numbers and
it is what it is so so i would have to
do something so i'd be like you know
we do something called send in the jew
and dana would go in there and like
because as an artist
you just want to take the deal they're
like hey dude you do the weekend
we give you a ham sandwich every night
you're like oh please and then you were
like
i wish i hadn't taken that deal but i
need the work i send in dana
she'd be like you know nah and they
flip real quick because they realize
they they're talking to someone
he went desperate and she would help
broke her deals
and i was blessed it was i would i was a
shark dude i had to keep swimming
had you could only you know eat what you
kill
it's crazy how
you learn to start saying no like
there's so many aspects
like i had all these plans to write a
book and i outlined it
and then it went down the drain they
they found out about the rogan thing and
they never called back
and in a way i was happy because it
really wasn't the book i wanted right
now i want to write about what happened
the last 30 years
i would love to think that what happened
the last 30 years
is more relevant we're touching back
to where i was sleeping in a rocket ship
just the last 30 years this
last three weeks knowing that i had to
leave here
has really inspired me to look back
at my 23 years at the store and
it also made me realize that i was made
for the store from day one
people were asking me has mitzy seen you
yet
since i first got on stage people were
asking me is mitzi senior
so that's the one part of it the other
part of it was what i was talking to
somebody about the other day
i think we were co-dependent on the
storm i think what's going on with a lot
of comics right now
isn't it the epidemic or the money
it's the withdrawals from what the store
was
i think it took me for about a week i
went down there two weeks ago i said my
goodbyes i took some pictures
and i knew i would never be there again
the next time i come here it'll be an
apartment building or something
i hope not i hope not
but it all depends on how long the
pandemic lasts
but my biggest
thing in comedy was that when i got here
i was already long in the tooth
i was 32 maybe
i was 34 so i was already considered old
at that time people were like
if you're not 24 leave [ __ ] you
tim allen's a hundred his partner with
the glasses the goofy fat [ __ ]
the price is right he's a hundred
they're all [ __ ] a whoopi goldberg's
a thousand
joan rivers and you're telling me that
y'all 34 year old comics aren't gonna
[ __ ] work
go [ __ ] yourself and
you know that yeah doing theaters with
joe
and you know opening for mooney on the
road and
paul rodriguez all that was exciting but
i'm gonna tell you what the
most exciting thing to me was
so far was watching the growth of the
comics around me
i watched you become a man
i watched dean delray become a comic
i saw the agostino go from a [ __ ]
pushover
to taking control of his life i love it
married
you see the growth
when i see growth it makes my dick hard
especially in comedy you know little
esther
you know little esther is little esther
but little esther had a big
desire killing it to get it you know
that's what inspires an old guy like me
now
i love when the youngsters call me and
go hey
they offered me this what do you think
and i tell them stick to this do this do
this
and they actually do i love doing that
dude because
we've been through it like we we've seen
it all it's like lee's like
you got like a crystal ball no because i
see it
you don't have to tell me nothing i know
exactly where you are
at one point of your career and what
you're thinking
i know what i was thinking that a year
and a half and it wasn't outlandish i
wasn't thinking of no glamour
i wasn't thinking of hollywood parties i
just wanted to get
good i wanted to play walnut creek the
punchline
i wanted to do seattle the underground i
wanted to do the houston laptop
and this was just from a paper that was
called just the last
so i knew i wanted to do it right now
today
if you call me and told me let's go do
stand up i gotta tell you to go [ __ ]
yourself
because i'm just not in the mood i'd
cancel utah
not because i'm moving i would have
stayed an extra week and flown out of
utah
it's because i can't charge people in
utah 25
bucks for somebody who hasn't gone on
stage in five [ __ ] months
i gotcha it's just not gonna work i need
three months of working it out
20 people 30 people in the audience
one idiot can i take a picture go [ __ ]
yourself
you know can i shake your hand not after
you wipe your mother's ass go get the
foot take a hike
use hand centered you come to my shows
you want to take a picture you
better have complete cavalor and your
mouth covered so there's no more smiles
so what do you want to take a picture
for
two guys trying to be doctors two fake
[ __ ] doctors hugging together
look at us but you know i've watched you
grow dude
i mean you've really really leaned into
this dude like who you
are and like you know it's like i tell
people it's like man
in this day of like the internet
it is not about trying to make
these [ __ ] gatekeepers happy anymore
it is peer-to-peer and what they want is
that you
whoever you are and that is not get edgy
or get dirty
that is whoever you are crank that to a
thousand and i watched you
lean into it to become probably one of
the [ __ ]
just one of the most devastating forces
on stage man
you really are what if everybody goes i
wonder what kennyson was like
i feel like what you were doing and when
you'll get back to it
but you know what on that nice runway at
the store like
you just brought something so different
than everybody else and it was just
i go wow man this guy's really leaned
into himself
and really really found it man
and it's like it was fun to watch you
ari calan
you know renaisseezy like okay you know
i know cabarella got weird i
i i loved watching cabarillo early how
much
i loved john yeah i loved you it's just
you know
yeah it sucks that we don't see him
anymore and he's probably angry and i
if i saw him i i i jump on this one i'd
put my hand down and say i'm sorry about
what
happened yeah dude you know if you don't
want to apologize for what you did
you're gonna live with that forever yeah
i would just say listen
i was busting tommy's balls about to
line up and
i was young and i was stupid and i let
my ego get in the way
we're sensitive people you know if if
i'm lying to you may god strike me dead
i was thinking about him the other day
and how he's making a living he had a
wife he has a kid
vegas ain't gonna reopen soon he had a
residency in vegas yeah i mean but
that's still amazing
to have a residency in vegas yeah the
residency in vegas
which nobody knows what is going to come
back
you know
i was on the phone with i think it was
my brother today and i go you know i've
always been very
thoughtful of people you know i've
always been very
well if you if i give lee
and his girlfriend two tickets for the
lego games
it's going to cost me 600 hours you know
i would do that
but then on the other hand it's like six
allowance a lot of [ __ ] money for a
lot of money
especially when i paid 15 to see julia
serving
you know uh it's
it's you provided something on tuesday
nights you gave them
a spectrum of comedy for 25
30 which they would have paid 20
bucks they would have paid 80 bucks yeah
yeah
yeah and i thought that i really
appreciate when somebody gives you
a a dollars worth for what you pay a
dollar for
you know i got a pantry on now i charge
a dollar
that means don't expect a lot but i'm
still going to give you a lot
because of my work ethic today somebody
goes i really don't like this patreon
[ __ ]
i'm just supporting you because of the
podcast i said then go
i don't want your [ __ ] dollar why
would you give me a dollar to be here
tell me you don't want to be here so
interesting it's it's
it's we're living in just a weird world
but uh those last two years at the
comedy store
i we had this conversation that we all
became very codependent of the store i
remember stanhope mentioning it once
that you guys can't live without
that [ __ ] store you know and and it
was true
it's so weird though just think about it
and not this set
you gotta remember this time we went in
there as g's
think of the first time we were the
undergrads
and we would get beat up on we had to
follow [ __ ] eddie griffin
i had to follow dice every day for a
year good night for a year
when you were the understudy in there it
wasn't fun
being an understudy for us the last the
understudy years
for me the understudy years were 97
to about 2005 and then i started slowing
down down there i could tell the tide
was changing
something wasn't right you know my spots
were getting later
then rogan fought for me and he goes put
them on at 10 45 and put me on an 11.
and now comics started to hate me you
know but it was after my neck surgery
and they found that fat ball in my neck
and they showed me the fat ball i go
that's the [ __ ] comedy story evil
that's when people that's when you walk
down the stairs people like good set
and as you keep walking they're like
he's on blow you know what i'm saying
like nobody
can have any time too nobody could ever
give you your props like
50 of the people really gave you props
i was the type of [ __ ] i don't
come up the entire i like that joke
unless i really like it
like if i'm sitting there and i go wow i
wish i would have thought of that
i'm going to tell you after you come
offstage yeah man in your lowest moment
because
that joke worked maybe the rest of your
set didn't work or something
or it may be a joke that didn't work
that you didn't word it right i would
never come up to you as a comic and tell
you how to word it yeah
but i tell you i like that bit there's
something there [ __ ] you did
that with me
and they would say you're right there is
something there you're right
you know so it all it worked itself out
but
sam this podcast was basically
uh for three things to tell you goodbye
uh to wish you
the best that you got coming to you
because
uh you didn't try to go through the back
door and
sixty percent of these [ __ ] idiots go
through the back door
uh i'm a burglar by nature i was born to
go to the black door
and guess what i went to the front door
yeah
uh you were banned for three days i'm a
criminal
sick [ __ ] that took my balls out behind
judy canciotti on stage
and i never got banned she even told me
mitzi don't take your balls out no more
i missed that's the first time i hear my
voice is that going to be all right
yeah okay last thing i hope you don't
call me tomorrow and say we got to
bring sam back to i hurt you with this
mic
i'll bury in the wall like an episode of
miami vice i love you dude
i love you i love you and then and sam i
know you love me
i know you love me and that's why i gave
you the little gift the cbd lion to help
us out
i love you dude and i just loved what
you did at the store on tuesday nights
you brought it back to what comedy
should be when a host tells you to be
here at 8 30.
i don't have to tell you to have a pizza
i don't even care if it's a [ __ ]
what's the pizza you eat from the
[ __ ] oven that you make jesus
did you wanna know the journal i don't
have it once in eight years
i don't care if your wife makes eight
digiornos
she made something how many times have
you gone to the store to do a show
i love it and somebody gives you uh
damn cookies you used to bring donuts
and i get pissed off at you [ __ ]
because i didn't want to eat the
doughnuts because i knew i was going to
joe's pizza
so i was either a dog i would follow you
with joe's pizza because the guy would
always be showing me pictures
i ran into josie yeah dude that's good
pizza man
on a tuesday night chicken after two
donuts
weed and i even gave away liquor at one
time because i wanted everybody to know
that they were loved
you gave me weed edibles
pizza doughnuts and what were the donuts
from
the don'ts for were from oh [ __ ] uh
dream donut truck they were delicious
and i could be wrong but aren't these
edibles that we love from that show abx
abx yeah
abx was the one they would come in weed
for everybody
i got people i still talked to them
online i just sent them some money
they're good people dude justin is a
great guy
you know i'm not leaving that lane going
to be one of those people
last night l.a did not suck it was great
it was a great stuff it just changed la
changed right now and
uh i have a white if it was just me and
my wife
dog i downsized to this [ __ ] studio
i'd build a petition one of those
colbert petitions
and i'd make her take a shower outside
the bucket and me too
and we just cut our course down and wait
this out
and see what the [ __ ] happens you know
but with my daughter in the mix
not going to school no social activities
you know we were talking about ice
skating what happened ice skating
we would take an ice skating every
saturday with a best friend
from nine to ten no more ice cream i
mean
and now they're saying that corona is
going up amongst kids
right before the [ __ ] school year to
really you know if i move across the
country there's no school
you expect to see a [ __ ] brody too oh
don't say that brody too i miss brody
too
brody too and i'll do it on facetime
like a [ __ ]
like a colvin patient i'll i'll put
yours on the same thing
put the respirator on i'm leaving you
guys
but i got a surprise and also the rope
comes or like a [ __ ] thing what do
you call those
what are those things the gallows like
uh the gallo no the other one the
the [ __ ] thing that the [ __ ] japs
used to use the head gets cut off oh
yeah
guilty how good would that be just to go
guys
this is going to be a fantastic live
stream
nothing like you've ever seen all sudden
you go the chinese guy walks in with one
of those things and you're like
i'm gonna show you something and you
just cut your head off
on live stream people would not know
what the [ __ ] to do there are times
i wish i still snorted coke tripoli
because i would start a network that
every night i would do a gram from a
different location no face
no nothing just show the baggy go under
cut the coke up and go guess where i am
and then the camera goes dead
i would do that three times four times a
week to [ __ ]
i'd have people at home waiting all
night long because then i'd start doing
it at two
and at four and at six
and i put the camera and finger a girl
and listen to the moaning
and show them the coke rocks but not
nobody sees nothing
except the mirror with two lines on it
at all times
and i would get expressed vpn and [ __ ]
so nobody could find me what i'm saying
like that would be
so much [ __ ] fun like that's the only
thing i miss about drugs
that i would added drugs to this mix to
really [ __ ] with people did you see josh
wolfe does like shrooms and
70 000 people watch him live
dude think about that dude listen man
i love your dog we did acid church and
mushrooms
me eddie ahri and lee
did a hit of acid and sat here and we
watched
[ __ ] army take his shirt off and lay
down
the floor you know that four weeks later
he went to australia
he checks into the hotel and he says
that some girls like hi
welcome to australia and some guy goes i
got this
and he took care of hari i upgraded you
mr jaffaire
and he goes in fact i'm going to carry
your luggage or he's like what the [ __ ]
is going on with this guy
this guy wants to [ __ ] me next thing you
know the guy opens the door for her and
he goes hey
i really enjoyed the acid church lad
so what are your plans leave me with
what your plans are going to be for
right brother
i just have two daughters by the lovely
martha mckellen
i'm blessed to have uh ghosts and ninjas
kids
i love my kids very much so i'm chilling
you know i'm doing uh patreons and just
you know spinning plates to keep the
money coming in i love my kids
i've actually kind of blessed that you
know even though this thing is just
maddening and
you know you've been great i've called
you a few times
and i got to tell you you've made me
laugh
there's some people that are still
mortavon
but you have been great and uh
i think the rapping amongst us has
really helped us
yes uh talking everywhere you've got a
rap
you gotta rap and you can't be that
scared that you can't do a face to face
from time to time
we'll wear a mask we'll wear a mask if
you're at home right now
and you're struggling with isolation
you're putting it upon yourself
okay first of all the boogeyman is not
out there
there's no boogeyman out there i want
you to know that i want you to know if
you see 12 people
yes i suggest you to cross the street if
you see a food truck
and you're in the urge for some [ __ ]
[ __ ] piece of food that that food truck
sells
that's basically a piece of [ __ ] with
dirty hands
when they go to the bathroom in a bucket
in the back there's no bathroom on those
food trucks did you ever notice that
so they pissed me i never thought about
that so
listen to me you see that you walk away
you live your life cautiously but no
fear there should be no fear
i'm a little scared of walking into
a comedy club that has 300 people that's
putting people in danger you know you're
charles manson jr
did you see they finally closed the
comedy store la jolla
and the american comedy club today and i
said it shut them all down
why are we doing this you know what
comics you're all [ __ ] home
put up content online dude be creative
don't go up there with a microphone and
try to do comedy for yourself it's not
going to work
be creative so online do jumping jacks
online
people will pay for you peer to peer see
you do
jumping jacks online but do anything
except stand up
read poetry online once a day my girl
christy belich
reads [ __ ] fortune uh cards online at
10 o'clock
does it pay no but nobody's becoming a
millionaire right now
it will but it will not now but five
years from now when people remember yeah
that one night they were having a bad
night they were switching to the tv it
was the same [ __ ] on tv
rambo five lawn order
i could have escaped [ __ ] tanked
the same the office the same stupid [ __ ]
and you go on a computer to seek relief
and there's going to be one of us
it could be any one of us it could be
corey okam
it could be [ __ ] sam tripoli it could
be lee jumping up and down
yeah and for some reason you will find
comfort in that
you will not know why you were finding
comfort
on this fat guy talking about [ __ ]
robbing a jewelry store
but something is soothing about that you
know
you have help you know i don't want you
to call suicide hotline
now they got your number and your email
for the rest of your life they're going
to call you till you do kill yourself
that's a suicide outline does
they like the scientologist they take
your information then they use it
against you
did you bring up your boyfriend yet kill
yourself did you know they're like the
same thing
they reprogram you there's no suicide
hotline in the church's world
or in our world what i want you to do is
rap with people
help somebody dude get out of your head
get out of your house
number step number one get out of that
[ __ ] bedroom the boogeyman ain't out
there
put a mask on if you need to put gloves
on put the gloves on i don't give a [ __ ]
what works for you
go out there pick one friend one friend
and talk with him yeah and then pick the
second friend and you walk with him the
next day and every day you have a
walking partner you have two points of
view
you're talking to two or three or four
different points of view
i don't want your circle to be with this
an episode of friends
just saying an episode of phrase
the same episode of friends [ __ ] this
is [ __ ] you and two doing two dudes
tops
you know and you just rap and talk to
each other tell each other what's on
your mind
what your fears are what do you think is
gonna happen what's not gonna happen you
know
and and this will all be better then the
second form of therapy is the notebook
but you guys drinking and smoking pot
you know i mean every how many days i
wake up and i answer
emails of people who have smoked pot and
have freaked out
and they've written me a bunch of [ __ ]
the next day they hit me back and go
i'm really sorry that reefer really
affected me during the
pandemic before we go what's the next
big [ __ ] scandal oh
dude um i i think
it's all about this election dude so
be safe listen i want to say something
to everybody
i love joey diaz i love lisayet listen
to
go back and listen to old church of
what's happening now
turn off the news get off
social media it's going to depress you
get out help dude i'm telling you if you
do this right now
if you help three people a day just a
random person
just how whatever it is hold adorable
whatever your life will change
your life can be completely different in
365 days
turn off the news it's meant to depress
you yes the world's crazy
guess what when you open the door and
you walk outside it's a beautiful world
get out of your own way man there's
chaos out there but most of it's just
there to get you
[ __ ] angry and sad and these things
feed off your bad energy dude
you know how they say don't go to bed
angry that's what they're talking about
find happiness find a hobby learn to
make a dollar off the internet it's the
new main street you could [ __ ] do it
i do it i started doing a lot of shows
because i know people at home
need entertainment and they're tired of
hearing about boom boom boom
beating them down the world's a
wonderful place
find beauty in it dude and that's where
i'm at man that's why i'm at sam tripoli
find beauty you know what i want to get
out of here
because just
i didn't see the creativity here no more
once they started making marvel [ __ ]
movies
and it's not the same [ __ ] shows how
beauty is it though
i don't think the creativity is here
anymore it's just not
you know we live in a place that has
hollywood sign
on it right yeah you saw the hollywood
sign lee
and you've seen the hollywood sign on
they only shoot
30 percent of stuff here everything else
is outsourced
from korea to atlanta to kentucky
why because we don't get a tax break
here
it costs you too much to shoot in the
state where
shooting is supposed to happen the most
this is hollywood yeah you got a show
by new york you do new york exteriors
but you should they've always shot here
and we don't have that here no more how
dumb is that i want you guys at home to
listen to what my words are
we live in hollywood and they only shoot
30 percent of the stuff here netflix has
a studio in korea
netflix has studios in louisiana
new mexico because they give [ __ ] tax
breaks because i can make a movie
in peace how [ __ ] sad is that that i
can't make a film
in hollywood because it'll cost me
two extra million [ __ ] dollars that i
could save if i do the same movie
in indiana so california somewhere along
the line when you think of that
statement
that right there lets you know the state
of mind here
well what sam said is exactly right the
the internet's the new main street
it is the big blades i went to a u-haul
place today
and the time i was there i probably
there were like six or seven
groups i went to a salvation army to
drop stuff off it looked like it in and
out
people are leaving la because they don't
have to be here anymore
hey i had a great time i was here for
almost a decade
but it's a business trip no one really
moves here
for the beaches i don't ever i dude i
didn't go to the nightclub
i hardly went to the beaches we didn't
do nothing store
we didn't celebrate christmases with our
families
we didn't celebrate normal thanksgivings
because god forbid
you got a spot at the store i'm not
crying guys
i made the sacrifices now it's time to
unmake those sacrifices
and move to the next chapter of my life
nothing wrong with that dude
nothing wrong with that sam tripler i
want to thank you for the 20 years of
friendship
dude i hope you don't lose
i won't change it i hope you don't lose
my number and i hope that
once this opens up when you come to play
the stress factory
[ __ ] yeah dude bananas or whatever go
get some dinner together swing by and
give you a big hug and
uh you gotta go play my club out there
where's your club it's called the dojo
comedy it's in
morris it's in uh morris plains new
jersey
it's ran by my boy mike romanelli okay
and uh
it's a nice little small room right now
for they're doing outside 40 seaters
when it happens and it's not gonna be
far from you we'd love to have you come
down and sling that comedy dick and lee
if you're ever out there you're always
welcome brother thank you buddy
joey you're a good friend dude you're a
good guy
you know i was a crazy person back in
the day but i'm really gonna miss you
i know you're not dying we're not tired
but no cause everybody's going there
it's super sick
yeah super sad dude we'll miss everybody
yeah
hopefully we'll all be able to come back
and celebrate how hard we worked and how
far we came
and who knows it will ever happen again
but i'm gonna miss
everybody all you guys it's gonna happen
again
we're all gonna see each other and laugh
about this man i hope so
i love you all my heart sam tripley i
want your family to be me the best
ghost ninja what you'll be in theaters
my brother
this is uh these are the last few
episodes of the church and what's
happening now and uh
a lot of people are going through this
right now i'm going through it
uh we'll leave it you know and uh we're
leaving on top we're not leaving getting
chased out of town
haha beauty i mean i'm not joe rogan and
i'm not call her daddy but
oh you are yeah and we've been doing
this for eight years consistently so uh
and now for a word from our sponsors
i want to thank my man [ __ ] sam
tripley [ __ ] poor guy was crying he
made me feel bad
i'm so sad myself i'm sorry anyway
i want to thank you guys for listening i
want to thank sam uh
i watched the kid become a [ __ ] man
that's the truth he's uh
he did something that not a lot of
people do in this town he's one of the
best and i love him for it
the church is brought to you by and we
welcome you
gabby gabby insurance right now we're
looking
at ways to save money everybody is you
might not be
working but the rent car payments and
everything else is due
when's the last time you looked at how
much you're paying every month on your
car insurance
or your homeowner's insurance every
month you're overpaying for this stuff
get a low rate for the exact same
coverage you already got
plus pay less and keep your coverage
with gabby
gabby takes the pain out of shopping for
insurance it's straightforward
just go to gabby.com joey
and see how much you'll save how they
compare your current coverage with 40 at
the top
insurance providers like progressive
nationwide travelers
and will give you the best rate you can
get that's what i did
they showed me a dozen quotes and saved
me a ton of cash
on my wife's car insurance because i'm
giving my back
because i'm leaving on the lease but
gabby helped me out
they were that good my wife was happy
with them our coverage
gabby's customers save 825 every year
what could you do with that kind of
change huh
if i saved 800 you could do a lot of
money so do me a favor
gabby will get you the best rate
available to you you can take that to
the [ __ ] bank jack
it's totally free to check your rate and
there's no obligation
takes two minutes right now takes two
minutes just go to gabby.com
joey it's gonna take you two minutes and
see how much money uncle joey's gonna
save you
on your car and homeowners insurance go
to gabby.com right now slash joey
that's gabby g-a-b-i dot-com
slash joey all right and you're gonna
save money
the church is also brought to you by the
kings
what can you talking about draftkings
[ __ ] that's what i'm talking about
draftkings is a is a sports book that's
available
listen draftkings [ __ ] that's who
listen lately sports have been up in the
air as the pelican
who stole my hot dog in [ __ ] michigan
that time in saginaw
if i ever catch that [ __ ] bird i'll
stab him 10 times
you don't really know what's going on
with sports but with draftkings you know
where you stand
listen no more bookies all right i'm
sick of these [ __ ] bookies with their
attitude
thinking they're in the mafia made me
meet me at the diner on a thursday
you know call me a code go [ __ ] yourself
nobody even knows you exist stop playing
[ __ ] big shot
you want an episode of sopranos [ __ ]
knock it off all right
draftkings is a short thing but when
you want where you want and don't even
have to leave your house
that's what draftkings is all about can
you do it right there in your house
this week you're lucky the nba playoffs
start
download the draftking sports book now
all new users get a signup bonus of up
to a thousand dollars a grand
right now draftking sportsbook is legit
they're based right here in the u.s and
your money is secure
deposit and take out money anytime
at your convenience they have new odds
boost
and promotions every damn day
to help you rake it in and if draftkings
sportsbook isn't available where you
live
don't worry about it don't forget about
the draftkings fantasy app
they're offering a shot are you ready
for this write this down
one million dollars every day this week
and you're sitting there [ __ ]
depressed about nothing get your [ __ ]
life together
go to draftkings sportsbook right now
just download
the sports book right now and use code
church
plus for a limited time just for the
church family
all new users get a sign up bonus of a
thousand dollars what's that joey a
thousand dollars
a thousand dollars all right [ __ ] the
[ __ ] is timmy this check you're getting
from trump
this is draftkings [ __ ] they're showing
up with a g-note larue
so right now if you didn't hear me in
the back they're going to give you a
grand
at draftkings sportsbook app use code
church only at draftkings sportsbook
and here's the part the lawyers make me
say you got to be 21 or older
new jersey indiana and pennsylvania only
deposit bony requires 25 times
play through and restrictions do apply
see draftkings.com watchbook
for details you got a problem gambling
there's help call 1-800 gambler and if
you're in indiana call 1-809
with it and tell him uncle joey sent you
but if you don't have a problem
download that [ __ ] draftking sports
book app and use code church
and let's go to work all right i want to
thank draftkings
i want to thank gabby
dot com insurance
i want them to [ __ ] i want you to
contact them at gabby.com
joey and see how much money you can save
like guaranty uncle joey will save you
money
so i want to thank gabby insurance and i
want to thank draftkings
but most importantly i want to thank you
guys these last two weeks going to be
the saddest two weeks of my life because
i know we've made a connection in a lot
of different ways so
thank you very much for listening and
thank you for having our backs this
whole time all right
uh we'll be back wednesday i love you
[ __ ] thank you sam
thank you christ killer but most
importantly thank you guys for all the
support and love
stay black have a great week take this
mule lee
[Music]